this video is made possible by support
to my patreon and through youtube
memberships
it's been the council all along
[Music]
successfully pulling off a serialized
mystery series might be
one of the trickiest things in all of
television even something as
straightforward as a murder mystery
can be difficult to sustain over the
course of a season
but the truly bold take it a step
further
and present a series where the mystery
is what on earth is even going on right
now
many have tried from benchmark setters
like
life on mars or fringe to forgotten
shows like
early edition or wayward pines to shows
that failed to secure second seasons
like
flash forward kings and alcatraz to
shows that didn't even get to finish
their
first season like defying gravity and
the messengers
does anybody else remember the
messengers
because i don't my point is
that what one division set out to do
drop the viewer into a situation that
didn't make immediate sense and expect
them to stick around to find out
what was going on maybe an
easy hook on paper but in practice it's
very difficult to pull off successfully
even the more successful attempts
at this kind of storytelling such as
lost which arguably kick-started a
massive wave of such shows
floundered as it went along
you know but then maybe part of the
problem for lost and
heroes amongst others was running for
multiple seasons because that's how it
became clear just how much was being
made up as it went along
so living it to one season and
knowing how you plan to end should have
given one division the home court
advantage
and the ability to really nail
this kind of television so the question
is
did it
[Music]
now i have my own thoughts on this and
believe me
you will be hearing them but i also
wanted to get a sense of what
other viewers thought and just kind of
get a gauge of the temperature of the
room when it came to wanda vision once
the whole thing had wrapped up
i conducted two poles one on that
wretched hive of scum and villainy known
as twitter
and one on the community tab for this
very youtube channel
i gave voters four options and while the
specific percentages
of what ended up getting how much it
varied overall you can see the results
are pretty
consistent between the two polls with
the most votes going to it was good from
start to finish
and the few was going to it never really
gelled so that i mean that should settle
it right well
not so fast couple of hitches firstly in
both cases the
second most voted was that it started
well in lost stream
and then if you actually check the
comments
a new pattern emerges because it seems
that a fair number of people who
actually voted
it was good from start to finish had an
asterisk
to add to that usually regarding the
last one or two episodes
not strong enough reservations for them
to say that the show lost steam and
vote for that option but enough that
they didn't want a vote of praise to go
unqualified i kind of expected this
actually and i wanted to have an option
for
it was great except for the last one or
two episodes but twitter would only give
me four options and i wanted the poll to
be identical in both places
so while this whole thing that i
engaged in it's hardly scientific it
does seem to indicate a general trend of
opinions on the last few episodes being
lower than the beginning and the middle
so
how about we section this nine episode
series off into thirds which
conveniently the story actually breaks
neatly into distinct segments of three
episodes of peace
anyway and then we'll try and figure out
what went right
and what went wrong
so wanda vision begins by giving a look
at the day-to-day lives of its titular
couple lives that seem to resemble an
old-fashioned sitcom rather
exactingly right down to the canned
laughter and the boss coming over for
dinner plot line it's presented matter
of factly
not as a parody of 1950s style sitcoms
but a
faithful recreation of the character
setting vibe
and writing of those things if it
weren't for a scant few moments like
vision questioning what his job even is
or
vague references to marvel specific
settings like sokovia
you might be forgiven for thinking that
it's just a straight up tribute
to old sitcom starring two avengers for
some reason
it's really only the end credits where
that first episode
shifts to somebody watching the whole
thing on a tv
and there gets a sinister overtone to
the whole thing
the next two episodes move things up to
the 60s and then the 70s in terms of the
style of sitcom it's emulating which
establishes a pattern
that the audience can't expect going
forward and even despite that it largely
keeps up the facade
established in the first episode there's
a few more reminders that this
reality isn't quite right even by tv
sitcom standards with
bits like the radio and episode 2 and
herb trimming the wall
in episode 3 this is a bold start
it shows a real commitment to the bit
that i can certainly admire
if there's a criticism of these opening
episodes it's that your enjoyment is
going to heavily depend on how much you
like the style of sitcoms being emulated
that's
an aspect that'll matter less going
forward as the world outside of west
view
makes itself known and the episodes
don't keep consisting of
the pastiches almost entirely but in
these first three
if you don't have any nostalgia for
these old style sitcoms or just don't
care for that kind of humor
there's going to be a little bit of a
ceiling on how much you actually enjoy
them and that
was honestly the case for me but even
knowing that i was kind of groaning my
way through much of these first three
episodes
i was still intrigued enough to power
through and the show really did pick
the perfect bit at the end of the third
episode to cue that we're about to start
finding things out come episode 4. now
episodes four through six
comprise what was for me at least
the strongest section of the show
without dropping the initial concept of
the sitcoms completely the show
brings in elements of the mcu that we're
already familiar with
starting with the largely unexplored
event of people suddenly reforming at
the end of end game
and then getting viewers invested in
monica who we've conveniently already
been spending time with
on the show up to this point so it's not
like wait i don't even know how
this person is or how they connect with
anything we get an
outside look at west view start to
understand the hex and follow monica's
journey
bringing in the rest of the supporting
cast like sword director hayward
jimmy wu and darcy lewis dr lewis
sorry doctor it's well paced doles out a
pretty decent amount of information
without overloading viewers with
exposition
and still leaves enough questions
hanging to not
feel like the show has pulled the
curtain back all the way
episode 5 bounces between events in west
view and the perspective of the people
outside
but just when you wonder is this what
the rest of the show will be is there
really any more surprises to give
than the bomb of pietro strolls in
that was a hell of a wtf moment blew
a lot of people's minds and it was
frankly a heck of a flex
for disney to pull not sure it was worth
it in the end but
well we'll come back to that episode 6
doesn't have the same kind of bombshells
in it but it shows that vision is
starting to question
all of this and it presents the divide
between hayward and the trio of monica
jimmy and darcy
as he tries to boot them out of the
whole operation and then we hit the
ending cluster of episodes episode 7
returns monaco to west view
shows that wanda's control of everything
seems to be splintering
fitting given that we're now up to the
2000s and 2010 style of sitcoms with
fourth wall breaks
and the ending of that episode reveals
agatha harkness as the show's villain
how so that gives us agatha's backstory
as well as more insight as to what
happened to wanda both in her childhood
and immediately before the start of the
show and then episode 9 wraps it all up
with the hex being dissolved
and agatha defeated all good right
well
okay so let's talk about why this ending
doesn't really work or at least
why it doesn't work as well as it should
have done
i mentioned at the start that if people
took issue with the show
it was fairly consistently with the
latter parts
at least much more so than the opening i
mean
heck i didn't even enjoy the opening
that much but i'll freely admit that was
a taste issue
and not actually anything the show did
wrong
but i think there are some things that
the show did wrong
in that closing chunk of three episodes
first let's talk about what is almost
always the double-edged
sword of these kinds of what's going on
is the mystery shows
that of fan theorizing the inherent
advantage of this kind of show is that
if you can hook that initial audience
and that if
is the big gamble at the start of these
projects you are going to have one of
the most engaged and committed fan bases
any show could hope for and one division
had the bonus starting advantage
because thanks to the existing mcu fan
base there really was no
question of if it would hook its initial
audience
but that dedicated and engaged audience
comes with drawbacks bustling forms and
pop culture sites buzzing with possible
theories about what's going on and what
twists may be coming
is all well and good while the show's
running
but it has a nasty habit of kneecapping
how much that same fan base
is going to enjoy the actual answers
there is the petty element of people
just being annoyed that their own
theories were wrong or insisting that
what they thought was going on would
have been better than what happened
but it would be dismissive to assume
that is the case for anybody let down
with the ending i think
there's something that runs deeper than
that which is the simple fact that
a mystery answered means there's nothing
more to be done
with that mystery jack the ripper wasn't
the world's first serial killer
nor the most prolific and yet he's never
going to leave popular imagination
simply because we don't know for sure
who he was a mystery
can keep you invested indefinitely but
getting answers gives you a stopping
point a reason to disengage because well
now you know
as a personal example i've only seen the
first season of lost
and i absolutely loved it but i made a
conscious choice to not watch any more
of it
because what i loved about it was that
by the end of that first season
the answers behind the goings-on of the
island could have been
literally anything time travel
government projects aliens dimensional
rifts purgatory heck
it could have just been a wizard messing
with people for laughs there are some
who call me
tim it was all on the table and i
really didn't want to keep watching and
see those possibilities slowly whittle
away until
the true answer was revealed now i
expect i'm a bit of an outlier in
how far i took that commitment to the
mystery on a show like lost
but i think that same impulse exists in
most audiences that are drawn to these
shows at least to some degree
so in truth one division was always
going to disappoint a chunk of its
audience with its ending
just by virtue of being a mystery driven
show with a wealth of possibilities
and those possibilities gradually
narrowing down to a single answer
and it's arguable that is just part of
doing this kind of show
and it really isn't anybody's fault
but i do think there were two main
elements where the show misstepped
and it was their fault pietro or
fake pietro or fietro if you will and
agatha
and it's interesting to look at both
because the former
is a mistake on the meta viewing level
and the issues with it wouldn't become
clear until the last episode
and then the latter is a misstep within
the confines of the episode itself
so let's start with fietro
within the world of the show and indeed
within the greater mcu as a whole
the idea behind this is completely sound
somebody who claims to be wanda's
brother but is visibly
somebody else altogether and may just be
gaslighting wanda
that's not exactly how i remember it you
probably suppressed a lot of the trauma
fits in with the mystery vibe and the
what is going on
tone of the show as a whole having him
turn out to be just some guy named ralph
doesn't really matter because it was how
his presence threw
things off that was interesting who he
really is matters much less than the
fact that he's clearly not who he says
he is
but somehow still has the abilities and
at least some of the memories
that pietro would have totally sound
not a problem but of course the
character fietro doesn't exist
solely in the world of the mcu he exists
in the entertainment environment of a
fandom
that was guaranteed to lose its mind
because oh my god
that's the guy who played quicksilver in
a completely different set of films
but the story actually being told
there's no reason that feature needs to
be anybody other than just
somebody who isn't ph or classic but in
casting evan peters the people behind
the show
knew exactly what they were doing
[Applause]
what they didn't appear to have realized
though was the kind of expectations
that doing this would suddenly place on
the show
earlier i opted to not dwell too much on
people let down because their own
theories didn't pan out
and that was largely because most of
those theories were never backed up by
anything concrete anyway
they take one tiny detail that might
have just been a random easter egg or
even just flatly
nothing combine it with a cross-section
of information from the comics and spin
elaborate theories about
how at the end of the show we'd see dr
strange show up to help free wanda from
the clutches of mephisto who was behind
the whole thing these kinds of theories
are actually kind of the reason i don't
engage
in or with theorizing much in the first
place but while those kinds of overly
elaborate notions can
really be laid at the feet of an engaged
audience with an over-imactive
imagination
alongside things like jar jar sith lord
theory from star wars
any theories around the fact that fietro
was played by the guy from another
universe of films a universe that disney
now owns outright
those were directly spurred on by this
casting
and it's frustrating to find out that
the show ultimately thought
it could just drop that in and then go
nah it's nothing really and get away
with it
especially when you factor in that it's
been confirmed
already that wanda is going to be in a
film called
multiverse of madness
how could they think they'd be able to
light the fireworks of
we're totally going multiverse up in
here and then deliberately pour water on
the wick before it goes off and say yeah
just kidding
you're ralph boner
you know it's funny in my review over in
the break room of geeks even though
i didn't really do much beyond
suggesting a vague
um maybe it's this maybe it's this i
don't know i did make
one core assumption i seriously doubt
they're gonna make the mistake of having
it actually not mean
anything i assumed the people behind the
show would realize
they could not do something that would
set off this kind of mad speculation
and then try and shrug it off i mean if
nothing else
you'd think they'd have seen how divided
the phantom was over rey's parentage
in the new star wars films and gone yeah
we don't want that kind of reaction
but my point is the only assumption
that i made about the casting of evan
peters
was well it can't just be a meta joke
that means nothing
and guess what it was a meta joke that
meant nothing
and before some of you come at me yes
maybe in future projects it'll turn out
to actually mean something
or they'll retcon it in some way or
maybe they were using it as a test
bubble to gauge reaction to the idea
of integrating some of the actors from
things like fox's x-men without having
to actually commit to it yet or
whatever but even if any of that
happens it won't change the fact that
here within the confines of what was
sold as a complete
product it has no meaning
beyond a meta joke and in the end a
pretty weak joke at that boner
but again to be fair if it wasn't for
the meta aspect there wouldn't be a
problem with fietro
agatha on the other hand needs no meta
baggage to
not really work at all
first let me say that catherine han not
the problem she's clearly having a ton
of fun in the role she plays it with
aplomb
and as tends to be the case when i harp
on things this much
it's a writing issue now exactly
how many problems there are with agatha
is going to vary from viewer to viewer
basically depending on how much
knowledge
you came into the show with so if you've
never heard of this
character you might have been taken out
of the story by the end of episode seven
being the reveal of somebody who has
no meaning to you and the show doesn't
provide an explanation for until the
next episode
if you do know egg of the harkness then
you might take issue with the turning of
an often
morally complicated character into a
straight-up cackling villain
because we don't have an overabundance
of evil witches in pop culture or
anything so let's turn a nuanced
supporting character from the comics
into one of those
if they wanted an evil witch there are
others available the marvel version of
morgan le fay leaps to mind
and i i know marvel isn't
obligated to be 100 accurate with these
characters heck
wanda herself having powers unlocked by
an infinity stone is
already a notable departure from her
origins in the comics
and the mcu saw fit to not bring up any
of her romani heritage
but i don't get why you do
this much altering to a deep cut
character like agatha
since the only people who know who she
is are the same ones who'll know
how much this character is
unrepresentative of her namesake
but anyways no matter where you fall on
the spectrum of
who's that to wait they totally changed
the character
wanda vs agatha is not a climax
that fits this show
this is a show that starts out with a
facade of vintage wholesomeness
with a few cracks in it through which
viewers catch glimpses of something dark
and creeping and then proceeds to put
that same wholesomeness into sharp
contrast by showing its impact on the
people trapped there
and how it looks from the outside before
finally revealing this all exists as a
manifestation of wanda's
desperately trying to stave off the
grief
of everything she has lost up to this
point which is a recap at this point
includes her parents
her brother and her supposedly
impenetrable love interest who i'll
remind you
she had to kill as a noble sacrifice and
then be forced to watch that get
reversed and see him die
cruelly and pointlessly
nothing about that story tone or theming
points to a natural conclusion being
wizard duel in the sky against somebody
who isn't really behind any of it but
just popped in to grab a cup of magic
for herself
that would be like ending inside out
by having sadness getting a climactic
mma brawl against riley's imaginary
boyfriend
what's particularly frustrating about
all this is even if the show
truly believed that it needed an action
climax
which it doesn't but let's just indulge
the notion for a moment
she isn't even necessary in order to
have that because
it already has white vision who actually
does fit the thematics since he's
basically vision without the emotional
components
and vision has been questioning his own
existence
since almost falling apart when he
stepped outside the hex
so having somebody who's going all what
even
am i then confront an incomplete version
of himself
is totally fitting hell it's the same
thing
logan did for its final fight and the
show even understood the character in
question well enough to realize that it
was better to resolve that with a
philosophical conversation than a
fistfight
but it was still a pretty neat fist
fight so that's
getting to have it both ways right there
so agatha
isn't really needed for spectacle even
if you decide that you must have that
and she doesn't bring much emotional
weight either because she's got no
history
with anybody the actual emotional climax
of her confrontation with wanda
happens when the residents of west view
snap out of wanda's spell
and then beg her to set them free
or allow them to die confronting wanda
with the collateral damage she is
causing by trying to stave off her own
grief and focusing
inwardly to the exclusion of looking at
the impact of what she's
doing and while agatha instigates that
moment by
lifting part of the spell that could
have been caused by literally anything
and it would have played exactly the
same
wanda could have lost focus by
trying to help with the vision fight or
sword could have cracked
the hex a little bit from the outside
and the spell could lift just enough to
get the exact
same confrontation scene so agatha
isn't needed for the emotional climax
either
you would think that as a bad witch to
wanda's
good witch she'd at least work as a dark
reflection a sort of
there but for the grace of god go eye
character who is
emblematic of what wanda will become if
she doesn't stop diverting her pain and
instead actually confronts it and
processes it properly
that would have given agatha at least
some thematic relevance
but she doesn't even bring that to the
table because the glimpse of her origin
story
has nothing to do with loss
or grief and she appears to be motivated
only by lust for power which has
no connection to where wanda is in her
life or really
anywhere where she has been up to this
point
yeah yeah post credit scene maybe she's
headed down that path now but you know
what
screw that a story cannot make or break
on a bonus scene
the only way in which agatha connects to
wanda
at all is that they both mess with
people's minds
but whereas wanda has rationalized
reasons for doing it
agatha seems to just get off on screwing
with people
and on paper maybe you could connect
those but again
the core motives behind their actions
bear no
resemblance to each other so that means
they just
don't link up what is so
infuriating about agatha isn't just that
she doesn't fit into the story properly
it's that there's absolutely no need for
any character
to be in her assigned role in the first
place the show revealed itself to be
about
emotional trauma trying to cope with
that
accepting loss showing how trying to
shield yourself from loss
doesn't work and potentially harms
others around you
and if you remove agatha completely all
of the tools
needed to tell that story are still
present
they had all the ingredients they needed
to make a perfectly good cake
and for some reason they just decided to
pour a bunch of turkey gravy on it
agatha's presence and the action climax
models the emotional throughline of the
show for those last three episodes
and that through line was really solid
one of the other things i found while
checking twitter reactions
was how many people were moved by the
episodes digging into wanda's loss
and that line from vision about grief
that seems to have flat out broken some
folks in the best way
but what is grief if not
love persevering
i guess for me i ultimately the
disappointment of one division
was seeing it lose its nerve
in the last few episodes i mentioned how
i didn't really love
those first three episodes but i did
admire the commitment
and the boldness it set me up to hope
that that boldness would carry through
and at first it did but then at the end
for no other evident reason than because
it's superheroes it throws in a
pointless villain for a climactic fight
that the show didn't need and nobody was
asking for
the show was so sure of itself at the
start
but by the end it went back to what it
assumed
were the expectations of a superhero
show and became
something far less unique
missing the fact that people were going
to connect with it
largely for the ways in which it wasn't
a standard superhero story
that's just infuriating not all
superhero stories need to end in a fight
because
superheroes aren't actually a genre
they're a character type
and they can be used to tell many
different kinds of stories from family
drama to space opera to espionage and
yes
i recognize that most of those stories
can and do
end in action scenes but if the core of
your story
isn't about defeating the villain or
what the villain represents
or using the villain confrontation to
show the hero's growth
then maybe you just flat out don't need
a villain
i'm looking forward to the day that
marvel realizes
it's big enough and its foundation is
strong enough
to prop up not just action genres
but any genre just any story
and for about six episodes i thought
one division marked the start of that
day
it didn't and given what's on the
horizon for marvel i don't know what
else possibly
could herald that day and it may never
come
but i hope that if kevin feige and his
producing partners are pondering over
the mixed reaction to the finale of one
division they'll realize the mistake
wasn't stepping outside the superhero
genre but it was forcing superhero
tropes
back in when they weren't necessary
that's one division largely me
breaking down why it kind of falls apart
at the end again at least for me
and maybe it falls apart harder for me
than for other people
but it doesn't look like i'm alone in
that assessment that it didn't end
quite right and i think the
disjointedness
of bringing in a villain for a magic
fight
really kind of is at the heart of that i
mean the stuff with vietro doesn't help
but agatha her presence at all
and her use really is
just a letdown for this show
what did you think about wanda vision
either the show itself
or what i've had to say about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
i have a patreon which is how i make my
living and what enables this entire
operation
to keep running i now also have youtube
memberships if you wish to support me
that way
as well both have perks and
it is my birthday this month so that'd
be a very lovely present if you wanted
to do something nice for me
but even if you aren't able to do that
the usual stuff liking sharing
subscribing that all helps me out helps
the channel
but you don't have to do that either
because
at the end of the day you are the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign